bonsoir ce soir sur le plateau du 7-8
société nous allons parler de la charte
de la laïcité dans les établissements
scolaires qui doit être affiché à la
fois dans les écoles dans les collèges
dans les lycées charte qui a été
présenté par le ministre de l'éducation
vincent peillon le 8 septembre dernier
alors cette charte at elle son utilité
ou pas indispensable ou gadget voilà
pour en débattre thierry fauconnier
bonsoir vous êtes secrétaire
départemental du syndicat national des
personnels de direction votre syndicat
avait demandé sept shirt et vous êtes
aussi proviseur au lycée
dumont-d'urville à elancourt en face de
vous françois andré bonsoir bonsoir vice
président de la fcpe des yvelines vous
représenter les parents d'élèves du
collège mais prêt à monter je suis
l'appartement tout à fait ces poissons
alors personnellement vous dites vous
que cette charte n'apporte pas forcément
grand chose allez nous expliquer ça dans
quelques instants si vous marshall
bonsoir réponse au secrétaire
départemental du parti de gauche alors
pourquoi un invité politique sur ce
plateau tout simplement parce que votre
parti par la voix de jean luc mélenchon
a dit que la laïcité n'était pas un
gadget alors nous direz comment vous
considérez justement cette charte est ce
que c'est un gadget ou pas vous ne
répondrez dans quelques instants enfin
henri viii des rangs bonsoir vous êtes
membre du site adl comité d'information
d'action pour la défense de la laïcité
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et vous
qu'il faut sans cesse rappeler
l'importance de la laïcité que c'est
donc une bonne chose ah voilà pour le
tour de table de mes invités de ce soir
avant de débattre entre vous je voudrais
ailleurs juste donner une définition de
la laïcité en tout cas se trouvait dans
le dictionnaire le larousse la laïcité
conception et organisations de la
société fondée sur la séparation de
l'église et de l'état et ce qui exclut
les églises de l'exercice de tout
pouvoir politique ou administratif et en
particulier de l'organisation de
l'enseignement voilà pour cette
définition de laïcité et maintenant on
va voir l'objet de tous les débats de ce
soir c'est la fameuse charte alors il ya
quinze articles dans cette charte les
cinq premiers rappel les notions de
laïcité au sens large au sein de la
république et puis les 9 autres articles
rappelle que l'école est laïque dont
l'article 12 qu'on l'on vient de voir et
l'article 14 qui précise que le port des
signes religieux est interdit pour cette
charte de la laïcité leur première
question messieurs autour de cette table
gym tomber retient il faut cogner
puisque votre syndicat l'avait demandé
est-ce qu'il fallait vraiment une charte
supplémentaires en complément d'une loi
qui existe déjà de 2004 sur la laïcité
la loi de 2004 portait quand même
précisément sur les signes ostentatoires
et donc in et s'il était nécessaire
quand même il nous semblait en tout cas
pour nos snp de haine de rappeler les
principes qui sont des principes
républicains la laïcité c'est une des
valeurs de la république c'est l'école
de la république et nous pensions que
dans un établissement scolaire il était
toujours bon de rappeler ces principes
qui font finalement là qui sont la
garantie qu dans une école dans un
collège dans un lycée on peut échanger
librement sans faire par forcément s'en
défendre forcément ses propres idées on
va pas parler de votre syndicat en
particulier où vous le dise il ya des
problèmes qui sont rencontrés dans votre
établissement lycée dumont-d'urville à
elancourt mais quels sont les problèmes
concrets qui ont été rencontrés par les
chefs d'établissement et qui ont poussé
votre syndicale de l'inde est en tout
cas souhaité cette charte on a quand
même un certain nombre de prises de
position de la part de parents parfois
d'élèves sur les contenus des programmes
sur tel ou tel point abordé par par un
enseignant est donc
parfois ça peut être source de tension
de refus de travail simplement sans
parler de phénomène d'une très
spectaculaire et donc il faut parfois
avoir des les outils pédagogiques et la
charte c'est un outil pédagogique pour
rappeler que dans les programmes il ya
des parties incontournable sur les idées
sur les idées religieuses et qu' on
n'est pas là pour défendre des idées
religieuse mais pour les apprendre à les
connaître
françois andré pour les parents d'élèves
vous vous dites en gros cette charte
c'est bien mais bon la porte pas
forcément grand chose par rapport à la
loi de 2004 oui enfin et elle aurait
fallu agir il ya déjà dans les livrets
de nos enfants des rappels de la loi
elle a été difficile quand même à mettre
en place cette commission stasi il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de débats
il ya dix ans presque dix ans et on ne
comprend pas très bien pourquoi
maintenant il faut remettre un peu le
couvert alors que on avait réussi à
avoir une application
dirait dans les règlements intérieurs
parce qu'il faut rappeler que les
règlements intérieurs parle déjà des
signes ostentatoires donc on comprend
pas très bien pourquoi il faut le
remettre sur une charte et puis parce
que cette charte elle rappelle des
choses qui sont ailleurs connu des
élèves entre guillemets c'est à dire la
déclaration universelle à la limite la
loi de 1905 fait partie aussi de leurs
acquis normalement alors est ce qu'il
faut le rappeler sous forme d'une charte
mais donc la séparation de l'église et
de l'état il en parle ailleurs il le
voit ailleurs et est donc ici sont des
rappels forcément nécessaire il faut
cogner justement comment françois
hollande est dit il faut ça peut être
mais dans leur règlement intérieur et à
la limite ça suffit c'est dans le
règlement intérieur évidemment mais le
règlement intérieur il fait 15 20
parfois trente pages on va pas forcément
le lire tous les jours alors que la
charte elle est posée à l'entrée de
l'école ou du collège c'est un peu comme
si on disait c'est pas la peine
d'affiché liberté égalité fraternité sur
le fronton de la mairie puisque tout le
monde le sait on le met quand même voilà
et le rap établissement elle est
affichée dans les thèmes fiché dans le
hall the
face à mon bureau dans la salle datant
de l'administration d'accord en mai
dernier votre avis alors sur cette
charte de la laïcité ont représenté le
comité d'information de défense de
laïcité sur 50 ans oui alors déjà je
veux répondre à ce que vous avez dit que
les élèves le savent or j'ai rencontré
de nombreux élèves quand leur parlais la
laïcité il savait même pas ce que ça
voulait dire parce que soient ses les
parents qui n'auront pas dit il ont pas
eu la curiosité enfin quelles que soient
les raisons donc personnellement je
trouve que c'est un très bon rappel
parce qu'il faut vraiment le dire il
faut le l'enseigné même si même si ça
pourrait être rappelle alors on est un
peu partagé dans le cia des ailes parce
que il y en a certains il y en a certes
a dit à des collègues à moi qui disent
que c'est un écran de série 2 de fumer
ou encore cachés pour cacher le fait qu'
il ya toujours le concordat d'alsace et
en lorraine ya toujours les ou des
prêtres sont payés il y a toujours
des subventions qui s'en occupent des
subventions qui sont donnés au cul etc
etc ceci je partage ce point de vue là
par contre je ne trouve pas que c'est un
rideau de fumée que sais je trouve
personnellement que c'est très important
j'ai envoyé mon gadget c'est vrai que
servait provocateur c'est jean luc
mélenchon qui en a parlé on connaît
l'homme effectivement vous pour le parti
de gauche verriez que c'est un gadget ou
mourinho surtout ce n'est pas une
politique de la laïcité on attend
quelque chose d'autre des ministres de
la république quand il ne s'empare d'un
thème comme de la laïcité car un thème
fondateur dans la république française
depuis 1905 il ya de nombreuses actions
à mener il y en a quelques unes qui ont
été cités notamment le concordat
d'alsace-moselle puisque l'article 1 de
la fameuse chardy que la laïcité
s'applique sur tout le territoire et que
la france est une république indivisible
toujours la percuter la charte c'est un
mensonge puisque il ya il ya une région
et demi qui ne sont pas si vous êtes là
glénac donc donc déjà cette charte
apprend des mensonges aux élèves enfin
en étant provocateur l'article un moment
et puis pour le reste ce n'est pas une
une vraie politique de la laïcité une
vraie politique de la laïcité c'est
remettre en cause le financement de
l'enseignement privé puisque aujourd'hui
18 7 % du budget de l'éducation
nationale va à d
des établissements privés sous contrat
et l'argent public pour nous doit aller
à l'école publique ça fait partie aussi
de la laïcité parce que 80 14 % des
écoles privées sont confessionnelles
dire il faut cogner qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait penser au long de votre
syndicat effectivement il faudrait il
faudrait aller plus loin parce que moi
je dirais simplement que les deux ne
sont pas incompatibles
effectivement ou à cnp de haine
également on voudrait davantage de
transparence pour sur le traitement de
l'enseignement privé sur le la manière
dont sont donnés les subventions à
l'enseignement privé maintenant ça
n'exclut pas de rappeler les principes
dans les établissements dont l'article 1
qui fait référence finalement à des
choses qui ne se passe pas en france
dans certaines régions de france il
rappelle quand même un principe général
le concordat ouiiiii libye l'alsace et
la moselle
oui mais y'a papa il agit vial qui a pas
que la charte qu'ils rappellent
donc ça n'empêche pas qu'on puisse
demander à ce que la laïcité soit
appliquée de la même manière sur tout le
territoire mais en même temps pourquoi
pas l'affiché voilà d'une part d'autre
part
est-ce que ce sera suffisant pas
nécessairement là on est dans le domaine
de la pédagogie c'est normal on est dans
l'éducation nationale
maintenant peut-être un moment donné si
cette charte ne suffit pas peut-être
faudra-t-il légiférer sur certains
points mais par exemple
je sais pas encore
d'après là c'est plus + l'historien qui
va qui va parler qui va regarder vers le
passé tout ce qu'ils auraient à remettre
un petit peu dans le même ordre de
marche ça peut être une charte évolutive
pourquoi pas ses impôts mais les
principes sont à évolutif qui sont les
mêmes depuis 17 100 quel point
le plus loin et que et et en particulier
que ça ne cache pas des renoncements
c'est à dire que on espère aller un peu
plus loin effectivement dans l'égalité
sur tout le territoire on espère aller
un peu plus loin dans le financement de
l'école publique c'est à dire que nous
ce qui nous importe c'est que l'école
publique soit c'est que les fonds de
publics de l'état arrivé à l'école
publique or on sent bien que l'équipe
actuelle le gouvernement actuel ne veux
pas parler de cette question c'est à
dire qu' il n'est pas question de parler
de la loi debré il n'est pas question de
parler la loi carle alors que nous avons
régulièrement rappelé que c'est injuste
de continuer
on peut pas comment dire rappeler des
principes en permanence de laïcité qui
renvoie un petit peu les religions dans
dans un comment dire de manière un peu
n'est qu'une image un peu négatif des
religions et puis d'un autre côté
consacrer 10 milliards d'euros par an à
l'enseignement confessionnel donc là
qu'on la séparation de l'église et de
l'état
c'est très bien de la rappeler dans une
charte mais il faut aussi que l'état
s'interroge lui-même
quand donc la réponse je vous rejoins
donc
analyse hâtive au marché j'irai même
plus loin le problème c'est quand le
ministre se contredit c'est à dire que
il affirme dans sa charte que l'école
doit être soustraite aux influences
extérieures or rien n'est fait pour
lutter contre l' influence des marques
il ya des associations qui proposent de
faire des interventions auprès des
jeunes pour leur montrer l'influencé
néfaste des grandes marques par exemple
dans les établissements scolaires or
l'éducation nationale ne favorisent pas
ce genre d'intervention d'autres
d'autres éléments sur les programmes
d'histoire géographie le ministre est en
train d'accepter de d'alléger les
programmes d'histoire-géographie au
lycée ce qui est pour nous une bonne
chose mais il se trouve que les partis
qui sont retirés les partis qui sont
retirés de ce programme c'est quoi c'est
l'échec de la guerre américaine au
vietnam or c'est un sujet d'actualité
l'échec des guerres américaines quand on
voit ce que fait le premier le président
de la république aujourd'hui dans son
alignement sur sur la peau neuve on est
très loin de la laïcité mais ce qu'il
faut voir aussi c'est que pour nous la
laïcité c'est pas simplement comme on
l'a dit au début la séparation des
églises et non pas de l'église et de
l'état
c'est ce et plus largement de la
séparation d'une sphère publique et
d'une sphère privée et la possibilité à
l'école quand on parle de la laïcité à
l'école d'avoir une véritable 1 j'allais
dire un havre dans lequel les élèves
peuvent se questionner sur tous les
sujets et être en dehors de toutes les
influences d'ailleurs c'est un des
points de la charte être en dehors des
influences or ben quand les programmes
scolaires sont influencés quand quand
les grandes entreprises peuvent financer
quand on voit que une grande partie des
établissements scolaires font travailler
les élèves sur word excel du groupe
microsoft et non pas sur des logiciels
libres gratuits et bien on peut se poser
la question s'était
offert au sens large devenir vous-même
françois andré sur chose que ma vie dit
on préparé l'entretien maladie en fait
cette charte ne répond pas aux problèmes
des activités qui sont dites
périscolaire sert par exemple épreuve de
compte mais je ne sais pas en fait mais
peut-être que je suis les chefs
d'établissement répondrait mieux est ce
que c'est vraiment un outil qui va les
aider à avancer dans des problèmes qui
se posent effectivement quotidiennement
à l'école
la charte et scolaire on parle que de
l'école et je ne sais pas pourquoi cette
rentrée 2013 elle vient maintenant et je
me suis posé la question en fait après
notre entretien et je me demande si
justement c'est pas l'ouverture de
l'école dans le cadre d'un réforme des
rythmes aux au périscolaire qui créent
de nouveaux problèmes pour la laïcité
puisque jusqu'à présent l'école était un
sanctuaire finalement vous mettez en
posait son enfant à l'école ils étaient
aux mains de l'instituteur il n'y avait
pas d'intervention d'associations
extérieur ou du périscolaire dans le
carnet est ce que c'est une manière de
l'ordre kg de carpes durable m qui
pourraient se poser cette année ou halal
dans les grands le cadre des plans des
plans pdt très complices demander
pourquoi disent en avoir une en or mais
est ce qu'il ya un danger pourquoi
maintenant et pourquoi pas et pourquoi
pas avant il ya dix ans ce n'était pas
le même ministre donc faudrait demander
aux ministres précédents pourquoi il l'a
pas fait avant cela dit
moi je pense que c'est effectivement ça
peut être un outil pédagogique c'est aux
enseignants de se l'approprier à
différents niveaux évidemment ça va pas
se traduire de la même manière
l'appropriation pédagogique dans une
école primaire ou en cours de
philosophie en terminale l mais c'est
aux enseignants de se l'approprier
c'est en faire un quand même un outil de
communistes est un outil de
communication moi je pense qu'elle a
quand même aussi le mérite finalement
aujourd'hui
finalement si on est là tous autour de
la table c'est d'avoir aussi de
contribuer de relancer ou de contribuer
au débat sur une problématique qu'on a
un peu oublié par le passé et ça veut
dire qu à votre avis la laïcité est en
danger un peu plus en danger qu'en 2004
est ce qu'il ya une évolution
disons qu'il ya quand même
manifestement des interventions est ici
ou là de groupes communautaires
religieux ou plus loin au delà qui peut
être politique ou économique sûr il ya
un enjeu économique sur l'éducation un
enjeu de la compagnie des choses qui
s'est passé depuis donc
l'ami s'est passé des choses dans la
société depuis dix ans il y avait
l'école a beau être sanctuarisé
heureusement elle n'est pas là même qui
a dix ou vingt ou quarante ans donc moi
je trouve ça plutôt pas mal que la
charte de la laïcité relance le débat
après elle va nous aider à ça dans les
établissements et peut-être à mieux
faire comprendre
je rejoins tout à fait ce que vous dites
c'est à dire que ça doit servir de base
et cette base cpo bon indépendamment de
tous les problèmes qu'on avait au bout
d'une allée cité qui existe ailleurs on
est dans l'école hélas de servir de base
pour les enseignants justement pour
rattraper parfois ce que les parents 9
ne font pas ou même ce que la curiosité
c'est à dire que par exemple
je parle déjà au point de vue base
pensais apprendre aux élèves que si si
on fait justement la laïcité c'est pour
protester n'est pas contre leur religion
mais c'est justement pour les protéger
contre les extrémistes de leur religion
c'est à dire que les pratiquants du du
les élèves pratiquant d'une religion qui
sont modérés ou qu'ils ont appris à je
veux dire à respecter la république y
voit être attaqué par les extrémistes
que ce soit dans n'importe quelle quelle
religion si si si on fait pas quelque
chose
donc si on veut il ya déjà ça c'est à
dire leur expliquer le pourquoi pas ce
qu'on leur explique pas le pourquoi la
liste fait ça tombe comme un cheveu sur
la soupe
d'autre part il faut le relier aussi
pour les pour les directeurs d'école etc
etc mais par exemple entre autres pour
le problème de la cantine la cantine
personnellement je trouve que ça devrait
être une je dire des plats qui ne soit
ni cacher ni allah ni le vendredi pour
le poisson ça devrait être neutre qu'on
fasse des plats de substitution ok mais
on n'a pas à se plier et on doit pouvoir
si tu veux si vous voulez avoir une vue
ne sait ce que disait françoise andré
effectivement sur ses cantines pour moi
c'est une base
juste une petite question qu'on se pose
aussi nous c'est sachant que
l'enseignement privé est payé en partie
par des fonds publics et notamment les
enseignants et les écoles privées sous
contrat et copréside avec la question
est ce que la charte de la laïcité
devrait pas s'appliquer dans les écoles
privées
revient seul
hic c'est un outil pédagogique et que
c'est il faut s'en emparer et s'appuyait
fera sans les cours etc c'est un
problème si elle ne s'applique pas non
plus dans les écoles primaires alors là
je rejoins totalement ce qu est ce que
vous dites mais c'est personnel c'est
pas parce qu'on est partagée pareil je
me la fait de leur nette pour pour le
dire et moi je pense que si on parle
justement du privé je dirais même que
dans ont fait toujours le public et le
privé et personnellement je trouve qu
une entreprise où il ya des salariés et
bien les salariés ils devraient rentrer
toute entreprise devrait être
sous-entendu au départ privé c'est à
elle de se déclarer non je ne suis pas
privé je suis confessions et c est pas
faire linverse c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'elle se déclare laïque et là je suis
tout à fait d'accord mais là bon on n'a
pas les mêmes
puis après une dernière question à poser
sur le mode d'application au fait de
cette charte qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
après une fois qu'on l'a affichée dans
son établissement qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait après je vous propose d'aller à la
rencontre des habitants nous sommes
allés dans la rue pour leur avait
demandé effectivement c'est une charte
de la laïcité c'était utile ou pas selon
eux on écoute leur réponse ça peut être
utile pour
mettre un petit peu les choses au clair
et savoir un petit peu
ceux qui éventuellement la religion et
que tout le monde puisse croire ou ne
pas croire en ce qu'il veut sans imposer
aux autres sa propre opinion et cité oui
à condition de l'approfondir je trouve
que c'est bien y'a pas de soucis au
contraire il faut qu'ils apprennent de
compte tant qu'ils sont petit ça use
rapts et des problèmes plus tard essayer
de réguler les éventuels problèmes qui
peuvent qu'il peut y avoir dans les
écoles et des collèges
sur les phénomènes de
laïcité surtout les phénomènes de
religion à côté qui sont directement
liés
ils sont assez favorables alors la mise
en la mise en place de cette charte de
la laïcité donc on a vu elle est
accrochée dans les établissements
scolaires j'ai contacté plusieurs
établissements aujourd'hui à 50 en une
qui me confirmait qu'il n'y avait pas de
souci dans mon collège des prés n'y a
pas de souci non plus dans votre
établissement vous ne l'avez dit et vous
en attendiez aussi une autre alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait après le travail
que les enseignants il faut cogner
comment vous avez est ce que vous allez
travailler ce que vous aimeriez vous en
six ans je travaillais dessus je vais
dire je vais dire quelque chose qui
paraît être une évidence c'est que les
enseignants ils sont là pour renseigner
leur discipline voilà à travers cet
enseignement ils sont ils ont fait le
choix d'enseigner dans l'école publique
dont de défendre des valeurs
après c'est sûr que en philosophie en
histoire en français plus facilement
pouvoir défendre l'idée de laïcité dans
l'école qu'en cours de mathématiques est
ce que ça fait d'ailleurs débat au sein
de votre établissement à ce que les
enseignants sont venus vous voir en
disant oh cette charte et les multiples
qui le pour l'instant prof de philo sont
pas de bureau et évoqué la réunion de
rentrée en disant que voilà ça faisait
partie des points d'actualité ça n'a
suscité aucune réaction particulière
tout le monde à bord attendait de
l'avoir vraiment maintenant ils vont la
voir ce qu'ils vont en avoir bientôt un
exemplaire dans la salle des profs et
puis on a eu après de voir comment
valoriser c'est important de lamelles
dans la salle des profs aussi ça me
paraît être important oui parce que
c'est quand même eux qui sont les
principaux vecteurs de la réflexion
puisqu'il s'agit de ça il s'agit et pas
d'enseigner la laïcité comme ça comme
une notion abstraite mais il s'agit
d'engager les élèves à réfléchir sur le
sens que ça donne
moi je crois que c'est un une bonne
occasion fin il ya l'article 15 qui est
qui qui enrichit la charte je trouve
qu'ils redonnent aux enfants aux élèves
le soin de
ceux qui n'ont pas par leurs réflexions
et leurs activités des élèves
contribuent à faire vivre
donc en fait en engageant un dialogue
avec eux et peu et entre eux et puis ce
qu'ils puissent aussi en parler je pense
que cet article là est intéressant qu'il
faut trouver les moyens de le décliner
dans la vie de l'établissement c'est
peut-être plus adapté au collège et au
lycée qu'à l'école primaire mais s'il ya
là de matière à un moment à faire à
avoir des projets ou transversaux
transdisciplinaires ce qui est dommage
c'est qu'on fait pas de philosophie
quand on est jeune
les écoles les écoles connaissent ça
peut être l'occasion de faire un vrai un
vrai travail avec
vous est favorable au fait qu'on n'en
parle plus large
et naturellement mais alors j'irai même
plus loin parce que on vit peut-être une
époque peut-être que j'exagère peut-être
mais on vit une époque où il n'y a que
des droits il n'y a pas de je veux dire
chacun ne veut pas avoir de ni de devoir
ni d'obligation on le voit dans tous les
domaines et je pense que l'éducation
pourrait se faire dix ans aux enfants et
peut-être ça va venir apprécions les
adultes parce qu'une société ne peut pas
vivre qu'avec des droits ça n'existe pas
il faut qu'un v6 n'ont cessé les petits
qui vont perdre un automatiquement donc
on pourrait leur dire vous avez vous
avez des obligations vous avez des
obligations pour ne pas faire telle
chose par fierté en trop tôt pour lui
il y a des obligations
il faut la faire vivre
la compléter par une vraie politique de
la laïcité mais concernant l'école un
tout petit revendications qu'on peut
avoir nous on soutient l'élargissement
du du rôle et de l'implication des
délégués élèves et ses cités dans la
charte et j'aimerais que ça se
traduisant en fait
pour le pour le cia des ailes on a
besoin de personne parce qu'il faut la
défendre cette laïcité comme je souhaite
je souhaite qu'il y ait beaucoup de
monde qui viennent bon ben vous
demanderai à catherine notre numéro de
téléphone 1 et puis vos dvd choix fait
par le secrétariat de la communauté
d'information défend la laïcité à 50 en
ligne merci en tout cas mon cas taton
venu sur le papier par les verts s'en
féliciter on aurait pu en parler encore
un peu plus longuement mais c'était bien
d'échanger vos avis 7,8 société est
terminée je vous donne rendez-vous dans
quinze jours pour un nouveau débat
n'hésitez pas à réagir sur notre site
internet et sur les réseaux sociaux je
vous dis à très vite